A splash of fresh water will reach the depths of your heart. Those mighty blue waves can propel you forward or they can calm and soothe. Coast to Michigan coast. Simply feel the flow in the moment. And let those vast lakes, rivers and streams create everlasting memories. Jump right in and let fresh wash over you in Pure Michigan. Keep it fresh at Michigan.org. Or on our website.
清凉的泉水会触动你的心弦。那汹涌的蓝色波浪既能推动你前行，也能让你平静舒缓。从密歇根的海岸到海岸。只需感受当下的流动。让那些广阔的湖泊、河流和溪流创造永恒的记忆。纵身跃入，让纯净的密歇根洗涤你的身心。在 Michigan.org 保持清新。或访问我们的网站。
Due to the nature of this crime, case file has elected to change the names of some individuals featured in this episode. In 1992, newlyweds John and Lisa Schneeberger were living a charmed life together in the small farming community of Kipling, Saskatchewan. John was one of just two doctors in Kipling and every time Lisa went into town, she was stopped in the street by well-meaning locals who told her how lucky she was to be married to such a wonderful man. She entirely agreed with them. Their relationship hadn't exactly begun in a conventional way. In the fall of 1987, Lisa had been working as a receptionist at a medical clinic in Oxbow, another small town situated roughly 116 kilometers south of Kipling. She met John when he arrived at the clinic to work as a physician. The 26-year-old doctor had only recently relocated to Canada from South Africa as he'd wanted to escape the political turmoil of his homeland.
由于本案的性质，Case File 决定更改本集节目中部分相关人员的姓名。1992 年，新婚夫妇约翰和丽莎·施尼伯格在萨斯喀彻温省基普林的一个小型农业社区过着令人羡慕的生活。约翰是基普林仅有的两名医生之一，每当丽莎进城时，总会有好心的当地人拦住她，告诉她能嫁给这样一位出色的男人是多么幸运。她完全同意他们的看法。他们的关系开始得并不算传统。1987 年秋，丽莎在奥克斯博的一家医疗诊所担任接待员，那是位于基普林以南约 116 公里处的另一个小镇。她是在约翰来到诊所担任医生时认识他的。这位 26 岁的医生刚从南非移居加拿大，因为他想逃离祖国的政治动荡。
John Schneeberger quickly became a popular figure at the small clinic, with patients finding him warm and personable. But he was still new to the country and didn't have many friends, so Lisa made an effort to be kind. She and her then-husband Rich began inviting John to have dinner with them, and gradually, something shifted in Lisa and John's dynamic. They grew closer, and Lisa's relationship with Rich, who had been her high school sweetheart, began to suffer. By the spring of 1988, Lisa and Rich had split up, and Lisa embarked on a romance with John. She took her young son and daughter to move to Kipling, and John went to, taking on a role as a doctor at the town's only hospital. Despite these sudden and drastic changes, the newly formed family adapted well. John was a loving stepfather to Lisa's two children, and they, in turn, adored him.
约翰·施尼伯格很快成为这家小诊所里的红人，病人们觉得他热情且平易近人。但他对这个国家来说还是个新人，没什么朋友，所以丽莎努力对他表示友好。她和当时的丈夫里奇开始邀请约翰共进晚餐，渐渐地，丽莎和约翰之间的互动发生了一些微妙的变化。他们变得亲近起来，而丽莎与高中恋人里奇的关系开始恶化。到 1988 年春天，丽莎和里奇分道扬镳，丽莎与约翰坠入爱河。她带着年幼的儿子和女儿搬到了基普林，约翰也随之而去，在镇上唯一的医院担任医生。尽管发生了这些突然而剧烈的变化，这个新组建的家庭适应得很好。约翰是丽莎两个孩子慈爱的继父，而孩子们也同样爱戴他。
The townsfolk of Kipling were as charmed by John as those in Oxbow had been, and affectionately referred to him as Dr. John. Lisa and John designed and built their dream home, a spacious lakeside property with enough room for more children down the track. In 1991, they married. As far as Lisa was concerned, she had found her soulmate, and couldn't wait to spend the rest of her life with him. Music On Sunday, November 1, 1992, there was a knock at the Schneeberger's front door. Lisa went to answer it, and, to her surprise, saw an officer from the Royal Canadian Mounted Police standing on the stoop. Identifying himself as Detective Hansstra, he asked if he could speak to her husband.
基普林的镇民和奥克斯博的人们一样被约翰所吸引，亲切地称他为“约翰医生”。丽莎和约翰设计并建造了他们的梦想家园，那是一处宽敞的湖畔房产，有足够的空间容纳未来更多的孩子。1991 年，他们结婚了。在丽莎看来，她找到了灵魂伴侣，迫不及待地想与他共度余生。音乐 1992 年 11 月 1 日，星期日，施尼伯格家的前门响起了敲门声。丽莎去开门，惊讶地看到一位加拿大皇家骑警站在门廊上。他自称是汉斯特拉警探，询问是否可以和她的丈夫谈谈。
Lisa called for John, and the two men stepped into another room to speak privately. Detective Hansstra informed John that he was investigating a very serious allegation. A patient had accused John of sexual assault. 23-year-old Candace Foster had filed a report earlier that morning, alleging that Dr. Schneeberger had drugged and raped her the previous night, when she attended the hospital where he worked for treatment. Detective Hansstra had already paid a visit to Kipling Memorial Union Hospital and interviewed the nurses on duty. One confirmed that Candace had arrived in a highly agitated state after getting into an argument with her boyfriend that had turned physical. A nurse had asked Candace if she would like to see Dr. Schneeberger, and she agreed. The doctor gave Candace a sedative that was used to treat severe agitation, and she stayed at the hospital overnight for monitoring.
丽莎叫来了约翰，两人走进另一个房间私下交谈。汉斯特拉警探告知约翰，他正在调查一起非常严重的指控。一名病人指控约翰性侵。23 岁的坎迪斯·福斯特当天早上早些时候提交了一份报告，声称施尼伯格医生在前一天晚上她去他工作的医院接受治疗时，给她下了药并强奸了她。汉斯特拉警探已经走访了基普林纪念联合医院，并采访了当值的护士。其中一名护士证实，坎迪斯在与男友发生肢体冲突后，情绪非常激动地来到医院。护士问坎迪斯是否想见施尼伯格医生，她同意了。医生给坎迪斯注射了一种用于治疗严重躁动的镇静剂，她留在医院过夜接受观察。
Neither of the two nurses on duty had seen anything suspicious, and both had been frequently bustling in and out of the examination room where Candace was treated. The only other male in the entire hospital that night was a man whose wife was giving birth, and he had been in the delivery suite the entire time. John Schneeberger listened as the detective relayed the accusation against him. When it came time for him to speak, he adamantly denied the allegations, stating, It wasn't me. I would never have done that. John explained that when Candace had arrived, she was hysterical and said she felt like killing her boyfriend. He had asked if she would like something to calm down, and Candace said yes, so he'd given her a sedative called Versed. John theorized that perhaps the drug had caused Candace to hallucinate and mistakenly imagine an assault.
两名当值护士都没有发现任何可疑之处，而且她们经常进出坎迪斯接受治疗的检查室。那天晚上整个医院里唯一的另一名男性是一位妻子正在分娩的男子，他一直待在产房里。约翰·施尼伯格听着警探转述对他的指控。轮到他说话时，他坚决否认了这些指控，并说：“那不是我。我绝不会做那种事。”约翰解释说，坎迪斯到达时歇斯底里，说她想杀了她的男友。他问她是否需要镇静一下，坎迪斯说好，所以他给她注射了一种叫“咪达唑仑”的镇静剂。约翰推测，也许是药物导致坎迪斯产生了幻觉，从而错误地想象出了一场袭击。
His description of the night's events were consistent with the nurses' accounts. Traces of Versed had also been found in Candace's system, so it was evident that the doctor was telling the truth about that as well. There was one easy way to get to the bottom of the matter. When Candace had gone to the police, she had brought a pair of underpants with her that she said she'd been wearing the night before. There was a semen stain on them that she insisted belonged to Dr Schneeberger. Investigators intended to obtain a DNA profile from the stain, and Detective Hansstra asked the doctor if he would be willing to provide a blood sample to compare with the result. Eager to clear his name, Dr Schneeberger said that he would be more than happy to oblige. The doctor soon made an appointment with the local police to give blood.
他对当晚事件的描述与护士们的陈述一致。坎迪斯的体内也发现了咪达唑仑的痕迹，因此很明显，医生在这一点上也说了实话。要查明真相有一个简单的方法。坎迪斯去警察局时，带了一条她声称是前一天晚上穿的内裤。上面有一块精液污渍，她坚称那是施尼伯格医生的。调查人员打算从污渍中提取 DNA 图谱，汉斯特拉警探询问医生是否愿意提供血样进行比对。为了洗清自己的名声，施尼伯格医生表示他非常乐意配合。医生很快与当地警方预约了抽血时间。
Candace Foster had reported the alleged rape to the Royal Canadian Mounted Police, or RCMP, in the Saskatchewan capital of Regina, about 150 kilometers from where she lived in Kipling. The Regina RCMP had subsequently handballed the case back to Kipling's detachment. A lab technician withdrew a small amount of blood from Dr Schneeberger's left arm, and then he was free to go. DNA was still in its infancy as a forensic tool, and it would take some time to receive the results. In the meantime, word got out around town that Dr Schneeberger had been accused of rape by Candace Foster. John Schneeberger was a highly popular figure, and many Kipling residents found the allegations impossible to believe. Not only did he have a reputation as a gentle and trustworthy doctor, but he had done so much for the town. John chaired a board for disabled adults. He had helped out two young men when they got into trouble with the law,
坎迪斯·福斯特向位于萨斯喀彻温省首府里贾纳的加拿大皇家骑警（RCMP）报告了这起所谓的强奸案，里贾纳距离她居住的基普林约 150 公里。里贾纳的皇家骑警随后将案件移交回了基普林分局。一名实验室技术员从施尼伯格医生的左臂抽取了少量血液，然后他就被允许离开了。DNA 作为一种法医工具尚处于起步阶段，获取结果需要一些时间。与此同时，镇上传出了施尼伯格医生被坎迪斯·福斯特指控强奸的消息。约翰·施尼伯格是一位非常受欢迎的人物，许多基普林居民觉得这些指控令人难以置信。他不仅以温和、值得信赖的医生形象著称，而且为小镇做了很多贡献。约翰曾担任残疾成人委员会的主席。当两名年轻人触犯法律时，他曾伸出援手，
and he had helped Kipling build its very first outdoor swimming pool by leading its fundraising campaign. His accuser was less well-liked. Candace Foster was a young single mother who worked at a local gas station. People around Kipling saw her as a party girl with a quick temper. At a cabaret event that Dr Schneeberger had organised to raise money for the community pool, Candace had caused the scene by arguing with her boyfriend and punching him. As the rape accusation became the talk of the town, most people sided with the doctor. They suspected Candace was inventing a story because she had a crush on him, or maybe she was after his money. After all, if she had been attacked in an examination room, then why hadn't she said anything to the two nurses who were on duty that night? Finally, after several months of waiting, the DNA results came through.
他还通过领导筹款活动帮助基普林建造了第一个室外游泳池。他的指控者则没那么受欢迎。坎迪斯·福斯特是一位在当地加油站工作的年轻单身母亲。基普林周围的人认为她是一个脾气暴躁的“派对女孩”。在施尼伯格医生为社区游泳池筹款而组织的歌舞表演活动中，坎迪斯曾因与男友争吵并殴打他而闹事。随着强奸指控成为镇上的谈资，大多数人都站在医生这一边。他们怀疑坎迪斯是因为暗恋他而编造了故事，或者可能是为了他的钱。毕竟，如果她在检查室里遭到袭击，为什么她当时没有告诉当晚值班的两名护士呢？最终，在等待了几个月后，DNA 结果出来了。
A profile had been created from the semen stain on Candace's underwear, and John Schneeberger was not a match. These results came as a relief to John and his wife Lisa. She had not believed the allegations for one moment, and finally there was proof that her husband was innocent. Now that DNA evidence had vindicated him, hopefully they could move on with their lives. Yet, to their shock and disbelief, Candace wasn't going away. John and Lisa found out through the police that Candace was still insisting she had been raped at the hospital and that Dr Schneeberger was responsible. She was demanding that they test his blood a second time. Dr Schneeberger duly agreed to provide the police with more blood for further testing.
根据坎迪斯内裤上的精液污渍制作的图谱显示，与约翰·施尼伯格不匹配。这些结果让约翰和他的妻子丽莎松了一口气。她一刻也没有相信过那些指控，现在终于有了证明她丈夫清白的证据。既然 DNA 证据已经为他平反，希望他们能继续生活。然而，令他们震惊和难以置信的是，坎迪斯并没有就此罢休。约翰和丽莎通过警方得知，坎迪斯仍然坚持说她在医院被强奸了，而且是施尼伯格医生所为。她要求对他的血液进行第二次检测。施尼伯格医生如约同意向警方提供更多血液进行进一步检测。
Once again, his sample did not match the DNA from the semen stain on Candace's underwear. Dr Schneeberger was definitively ruled out as a suspect. Because DNA evidence was absolute, the police told Candace there was nothing else they could do, and in 1994, the case file was closed. Lisa couldn't understand what had prompted Candace to target her husband so persistently. She wondered if Candace was infatuated with John and determined to ruin their marriage, or maybe she was mentally unwell. Whatever the reason, Lisa was furious with her. She knew without a doubt that Candace wasn't the victim. John was.
他的样本再次与坎迪斯内裤上精液的 DNA 不匹配。施尼伯格医生被明确排除在嫌疑人之外。由于 DNA 证据是绝对的，警方告诉坎迪斯他们无能为力，1994 年，案件档案被关闭。丽莎无法理解是什么促使坎迪斯如此执着地针对她的丈夫。她怀疑坎迪斯是否迷恋约翰并决心破坏他们的婚姻，或者她是否精神不正常。无论原因是什么，丽莎都对她感到愤怒。她毫无疑问地知道，坎迪斯不是受害者。约翰才是。
Life went on as normal, with Dr Schneeberger retaining his good standing in the community. Luckily, most people in the town believed in him wholeheartedly. Candace Foster made the decision to move 150km away to Regina, so the Schneebergers no longer had to worry about bumping into her down the street. Over the next couple of years, the rape claim faded into the past, and they moved on into their future together. The happy couple had two children, with their first daughter born in 1995 and their second in 1996. Life was good, and their family was finally complete. But still, the Schneebergers suspected that Candace was lurking about on the fringes of their lives. One day in 1996, a man approached John at work with an entry form for a raffle.
生活恢复了正常，施尼伯格医生在社区中保持着良好的声誉。幸运的是，镇上大多数人都全心全意地相信他。坎迪斯·福斯特决定搬到 150 公里外的里贾纳，这样施尼伯格夫妇就不必担心在街上偶遇她了。在接下来的几年里，强奸指控逐渐淡出人们的记忆，他们继续着未来的生活。这对幸福的夫妇有了两个孩子，第一个女儿出生于 1995 年，第二个出生于 1996 年。生活很美好，他们的家庭终于圆满了。但施尼伯格夫妇仍然怀疑坎迪斯潜伏在他们生活的边缘。1996 年的一天，一名男子在工作中找到约翰，递给他一张抽奖入场券。
He explained that it was part of a radio station contest to win a diamond ring, and asked John if he would like to enter. John agreed. He filled out the form, then placed it into the accompanying envelope, licking its adhesive strip before sealing it. The stranger had watched him carefully the entire time. This incident took on a sinister new light when the Schneebergers cleaner approached them with some information. She knew Candace Foster's parents and had heard that Candace had hired a private investigator to keep digging into John. Lisa was angry that Candace still seemed hell-bent on destroying their lives. From then on, John sealed envelopes by using water from the kitchen tap, telling Lisa,
他解释说这是电台竞赛的一部分，奖品是一枚钻戒，并问约翰是否想参加。约翰同意了。他填好表格，然后将其放入随附的信封中，舔了舔粘胶条将其封好。那个陌生人全程都在仔细观察他。当施尼伯格家的清洁工带来一些消息时，这件事呈现出一种阴险的新色彩。她认识坎迪斯·福斯特的父母，并听说坎迪斯雇了一名私家侦探继续挖掘约翰的底细。丽莎很生气，坎迪斯似乎仍然一心想摧毁他们的生活。从那时起，约翰用厨房水龙头的水来封信封，并告诉丽莎：
You can just never be too careful when people are accusing you of things you didn't do. On the afternoon of Friday, April 25, 1997, Lisa Schneeberger was at home when one of her daughters approached with a surprising question. 15-year-old Amy was Lisa's eldest child from her first marriage, and she wanted to know whether she could go and visit her biological father. The request caught Lisa off guard, as the family had already made weekend plans, and Amy was supposed to be babysitting. Lisa noticed that Amy's complexion was pale and her expression troubled. She asked her daughter what was wrong. In a halting voice, Amy replied, Mum, I have something to tell you.
“当人们指控你没做过的事情时，你永远怎么小心都不为过。”1997 年 4 月 25 日，星期五下午，丽莎·施尼伯格正在家中，这时她的一位女儿带着一个令人惊讶的问题走过来。15 岁的艾米是丽莎第一次婚姻中的长女，她想知道自己是否可以去探望她的亲生父亲。这个请求让丽莎措手不及，因为家里已经安排了周末计划，而且艾米本该负责照看孩子。丽莎注意到艾米的脸色苍白，表情困扰。她问女儿怎么了。艾米声音颤抖地回答：“妈妈，我有件事要告诉你。”
She gestured for her mother to come with her and led Lisa to her bedroom. Amy walked over to her bed and pulled back the covers. Then she pointed at the mattress. Lisa looked at the spot her daughter was indicating. Lying there was an empty condom wrapper. Then Amy spoke. Mum, he's done this to me before. The night of October 31, 1992, wasn't shaping up to be a fun Halloween for 23-year-old Candace Foster. For starters, she had a shift at the gas station where she worked full-time.
她示意母亲跟她走，把丽莎带到了她的卧室。艾米走到床边，掀开被子。然后她指着床垫。丽莎看向女儿指的地方。那里躺着一个空的避孕套包装纸。接着艾米开口了：“妈妈，他以前也对我做过这种事。”1992 年 10 月 31 日的万圣节之夜，对于 23 岁的坎迪斯·福斯特来说，并不是一个愉快的夜晚。首先，她在全职工作的加油站有一个轮班。
Candace had given birth to a baby girl nine months earlier, and as a single mother, she was solely responsible for providing for her daughter. Her parents, who came from a modest farming background, were supportive, but juggling parenthood with long working hours was exhausting. Second of all, Candace's boyfriend, Danny, had showed up at the gas station, which had led to an argument. Candace and Danny had a tumultuous relationship, and she'd just learned that he had lied to her about seeing other women. They began to fight, with Candace growing as distressed about the argument itself as she was about the fact it was taking place at her work. Danny made one last offensive retort, then jumped into his truck and drove away laughing with a friend. Furious, Candace kicked the side of the vehicle as it peeled out of the parking lot. She was so distraught and angry that she decided to go to Kipling Memorial Union Hospital to see a friend who worked there.
坎迪斯九个月前生下了一个女婴，作为单身母亲，她独自承担着抚养女儿的责任。她的父母来自普通的农家，虽然给予了支持，但兼顾育儿和长时间的工作让人精疲力竭。其次，坎迪斯的男友丹尼出现在加油站，导致了一场争吵。坎迪斯和丹尼的关系动荡不安，她刚刚得知他对自己撒谎，说他和其他女人见面。他们开始争吵，坎迪斯对争吵本身感到痛苦，就像她对这件事发生在工作场所感到痛苦一样。丹尼说了最后一句冒犯的话，然后跳上他的卡车，笑着和朋友开车离开了。愤怒的坎迪斯在车子驶出停车场时踢了车身一脚。她心烦意乱，愤怒不已，决定去基普林纪念联合医院看望一位在那里工作的朋友。
Candace hoped that talking through her feelings might help calm her down. She left work early, went home to change, and then drove to the hospital, only to discover her friend wasn't working that night. Noticing how upset Candace was, a nurse asked if she'd like to see a doctor. Candace asked who was on that night. It was Dr. Schneeberger, known locally as Dr. John. Candace liked Dr. Schneeberger. He was young and charming and had been her doctor for more than a year. He had even delivered her daughter nine months earlier. Candace agreed to see him and was shown to an examination room.
坎迪斯希望倾诉自己的感受能帮助她冷静下来。她提前下班，回家换了衣服，然后开车去医院，却发现她的朋友那天晚上没上班。注意到坎迪斯很不安，一名护士问她是否想见医生。坎迪斯问那天晚上是谁值班。是施尼伯格医生，当地人称他为“约翰医生”。坎迪斯喜欢施尼伯格医生。他年轻迷人，已经做了她一年多的医生。他甚至在九个月前为她接生了女儿。坎迪斯同意去看他，并被带到了检查室。
Candace's agitation had only increased since arriving at the hospital. When Dr. Schneeberger stepped into the examination room, he found her sobbing. Her face was bright red. He asked what was wrong, and Candace replied, I'm so mad at Danny that I feel like I could kill him. Dr. Schneeberger chatted with Candace for a few moments and said, Well, maybe I'll give you something to calm you down. He left the room briefly, then returned with a syringe in hand.
坎迪斯到达医院后，情绪更加激动。当施尼伯格医生走进检查室时，发现她在啜泣。她的脸涨得通红。他问怎么了，坎迪斯回答说：“我太生丹尼的气了，我觉得我能杀了他。”施尼伯格医生和坎迪斯聊了几句，说：“好吧，也许我给你点东西让你冷静一下。”他短暂地离开了房间，然后拿着注射器回来了。
Candace was surprised. She thought the doctor was just going to get her a couple of pills. He inserted the needle into Candace's right arm, then led her over to an examining table, rolling her over on her left side so she was facing the wall. Almost as soon as the drugs entered her system, Candace had felt them take effect. Her body felt heavy, yet soft at the same time, like all her muscles were gone and she was just a puddle of jelly. She tried to scream, but all that came out was a faint croaking sound. Limp and numb, she couldn't move. Yet her eyes stayed wide open, staring at the blank wall in front of her.
坎迪斯很惊讶。她以为医生只是会给她拿几片药。他把针头扎进坎迪斯的右臂，然后领她走到检查台上，让她向左侧翻身，面朝墙壁。药物进入她体内后，坎迪斯几乎立刻就感觉到了药效。她的身体感觉沉重，但同时又很柔软，就像所有的肌肉都消失了，她只是一滩果冻。她试图尖叫，但发出的只有微弱的嘶哑声。她瘫软麻木，无法动弹。然而她的眼睛睁得大大的，盯着面前空白的墙壁。
Candace felt a man unbutton and pulled down her jeans before pulling her underwear to one side. Then he started to rape her. Candace couldn't turn and see who it was. She couldn't call out for help. Desperately, she tried to move her arm. After a few minutes, her attacker stopped and fixed Candace's clothing. Groggily, she managed to roll over just in time to see Dr. Schneeberger exiting the room. Candace woke the next morning in a hospital bed, feeling light-headed and strange. Slowly, the events of the previous night came back to her.
坎迪斯感觉到一个男人解开了她的牛仔裤扣子，把裤子拉了下来，然后把她的内裤拉到一边。接着他开始强奸她。坎迪斯无法转头看那是谁。她无法呼救。她绝望地试图移动手臂。几分钟后，袭击者停了下来，整理好坎迪斯的衣服。昏昏沉沉中，她及时翻过身，看到施尼伯格医生正走出房间。第二天早上，坎迪斯在医院病床上醒来，感到头晕目眩，感觉很奇怪。前一天晚上的事情慢慢浮现在她的脑海中。
She hadn't mentioned anything about the attack to the nurses, who had encouraged her to stay at the hospital overnight. Soon, Dr. Schneeberger came in to check on her and take her vitals. As he went to check her pulse, Candace asked him what kind of drug he had given her the night before. Why? replied the doctor with a smile. Did it give you wild dreams? Then he walked out without answering her question. Candace noticed that her underpants were stained with what appeared to be semen. When she got home, she took them off and placed them inside a Ziploc bag. Having watched a lot of crime shows over the years, she knew she needed to preserve any possible DNA evidence.
她没有向护士提起袭击的事，护士们鼓励她留在医院过夜。很快，施尼伯格医生进来检查她的情况并测量生命体征。当他去检查她的脉搏时，坎迪斯问他前一天晚上给她注射了什么药。“为什么？”医生微笑着回答，“它让你做了狂野的梦吗？”然后他没有回答她的问题就走了出去。坎迪斯注意到她的内裤上沾着看起来像是精液的东西。回到家后，她脱下内裤，放进一个密封袋里。多年来看了很多犯罪节目，她知道她需要保存任何可能的 DNA 证据。
She would also need to undergo a physical examination. Candace knew she couldn't return to the hospital where Dr. Schneeberger worked, nor did she feel safe reporting the crime to the local police force. So she drove with a friend almost two hours west to a hospital in Regina, where she spoke with two sexual assault counselors and a rape kit was collected. Staff at the hospital phoned the police on Candace's behalf. Candace also confided in her parents, who would be two of her greatest supporters in the months and years that followed. One look at her face was all they needed to see to realize how traumatized she was.
她还需要接受身体检查。坎迪斯知道她不能回到施尼伯格医生工作的医院，她也不觉得向当地警方报告这起罪行是安全的。于是她和朋友开车向西行驶了近两个小时，来到里贾纳的一家医院，在那里她与两名性侵犯咨询师进行了交谈，并收集了强奸取证包。医院的工作人员代表坎迪斯报了警。坎迪斯还向她的父母吐露了心声，他们将是她在随后的几个月和几年里最伟大的支持者。看一眼她的脸，他们就意识到她受到了多大的创伤。
Although Candace's parents and close friends believed her, it was a different story when it came to the rest of Kipling. Candace couldn't walk down the street without people pointing at her and exchanging whispers. Rumors spread that Candace was obsessed with Dr. Schneeberger and was trying to break up his marriage. Others speculated that she was a gold digger who was trying to blackmail or sue a wealthy man for cash. Candace stood firm, knowing that when the DNA results from Dr. Schneeberger's blood test arrived, then people would realize she had been telling the truth. After six long months, she received a call from a Kipling constable. The DNA wasn't a match.
虽然坎迪斯的父母和密友相信她，但基普林的其他地方情况却截然不同。坎迪斯走在街上，人们指指点点，窃窃私语。谣言四起，说坎迪斯迷恋施尼伯格医生，试图破坏他的婚姻。其他人则猜测她是一个想通过敲诈或起诉富人来赚钱的“淘金者”。坎迪斯立场坚定，她知道当施尼伯格医生的血液检测 DNA 结果出来时，人们就会意识到她说的是真话。六个月漫长的等待后，她接到了基普林警员的电话。DNA 不匹配。
Candace couldn't believe it. That's impossible, she told the police, before adding that she would get to the bottom of the matter. Candace suspected that the doctor had foiled the DNA test somehow. Maybe he'd figured out a way to switch the vial that contained his blood. The police told her that wasn't possible. An officer had supervised the entire process and nothing suspicious had taken place. Still, Candace was undeterred. For months, she lobbied the police to test the doctor's blood again.
坎迪斯简直不敢相信。“这不可能，”她告诉警方，并补充说她会查明真相。坎迪斯怀疑医生以某种方式破坏了 DNA 测试。也许他想出了办法调换装有他血液的小瓶。警方告诉她那是不可能的。一名警官监督了整个过程，没有发生任何可疑的事情。尽管如此，坎迪斯并没有被吓倒。几个月来，她游说警方再次对医生进行血液检测。
In 1993, they approached Dr. Schneeberger again and managed to convince him to give another sample. This time, the doctor was indignant and protested, pointing out that he had already been exonerated. But eventually, he agreed. The second test had the exact same result as the first. Negative Kipling was where Candace Foster's support network of family and friends lived. But being around so many others who thought she was a liar was too difficult. Unable to continue living in the town where people treated her like a pariah, she moved to Regina.
1993 年，他们再次找到施尼伯格医生，并设法说服他提供了另一个样本。这一次，医生义愤填膺地抗议，指出他已经被证明清白了。但最终，他同意了。第二次测试的结果与第一次完全相同。阴性。基普林是坎迪斯·福斯特的家人和朋友支持网络所在地。但被这么多认为她是骗子的人包围太困难了。由于无法继续生活在人们把她当作贱民对待的小镇，她搬到了里贾纳。
Years went by, but she refused to give up her fight. In 1996, she decided to hire a private investigator and ask him to obtain a sample of Dr. Schneeberger's DNA for testing. Larry O'Brien had worked for the RCMP for 25 years before he switched over to private work. He agreed to meet with Candace, and as he listened to her story, he was struck by her strength and matter of fact manner. In an episode of the Canadian television program 72 Hours, Larry O'Brien described Candace as one of the most determined people he had ever met. Quote Tough as nails if she had to be, and sweet as an angel. Hearing what Candace had to say, Larry had no doubt that she had been raped and that Dr. John Schneeberger was responsible.
岁月流逝，但她拒绝放弃斗争。1996 年，她决定雇一名私家侦探，请他获取施尼伯格医生的 DNA 样本进行检测。拉里·奥布莱恩在转行做私家侦探之前，曾为加拿大皇家骑警工作了 25 年。他同意与坎迪斯会面，当他听完她的故事时，被她的坚强和实事求是的态度所打动。在加拿大电视节目《72 小时》的一集中，拉里·奥布莱恩形容坎迪斯是他见过的最坚定的人之一。引用：“必要时坚如磐石，甜如天使。”听到坎迪斯的话，拉里毫不怀疑她被强奸了，而且是约翰·施尼伯格医生所为。
When Candace explained that Larry was her last hope, he knew he had to help her. Larry had his assistant go to the doctor's workplace and pretend he was accepting entries for a competition. Dr. Schneeberger filled out a form and then placed it in an envelope, licking the seal closed. But the envelope was later contaminated and had to be thrown out. For his next attempt, Larry O'Brien went to the hospital parking light himself and tracked down Dr. Schneeberger's car, a Mercedes Benz with the personalized license plate, Schnee. The vehicle was unlocked, allowing easy access. It was also exceptionally clean, but Larry managed to find a hair on the back of the headrest. He carefully bagged it for testing.
当坎迪斯解释说拉里是她最后的希望时，他知道他必须帮助她。拉里让他的助手去医生的工作场所，假装他在接受竞赛报名。施尼伯格医生填好表格，然后把它放进信封里，舔了舔封口。但信封后来被污染了，不得不扔掉。为了下一次尝试，拉里·奥布莱恩亲自去了医院停车场，找到了施尼伯格医生的车，那是一辆带有个性化车牌“Schnee”的梅赛德斯-奔驰。车门没锁，可以轻松进入。车里也非常干净，但拉里设法在头枕后面找到了一根头发。他小心翼翼地将其装袋以备检测。
Unfortunately, the hair had no root, so it was unusable. Determined to keep trying, Larry went back to the car a second time. This time he spotted a tube of chapstick sitting in the vehicle's unused ashtray. Removing the cap, Larry saw that the chapstick was almost brand new. It looked as though someone had used it just once. Pulling out an envelope that had a clear plastic window pane, Larry rubbed the chapstick back and forth over the plastic. The third time was the charm. Traces of saliva and skin cells present on the chapstick had transferred to the envelope and there was enough to create a DNA profile.
不幸的是，这根头发没有发根，所以无法使用。拉里决心继续尝试，第二次回到车里。这一次，他在车里未使用的烟灰缸里发现了一管润唇膏。取下盖子，拉里看到润唇膏几乎是全新的。看起来好像有人只用过一次。拉里拿出一个带有透明塑料窗口的信封，在塑料上来回摩擦润唇膏。第三次尝试成功了。润唇膏上残留的唾液和皮肤细胞转移到了信封上，足以建立 DNA 图谱。
Two weeks later, Larry got a call. The results were in. The DNA was a match to the man who had raped Candace. Candace was overjoyed. She knew the results proved that Dr. Schneeberger had raped her. But it was still unclear why the DNA from his blood sample wasn't a match to her rapist's semen as well. Candace and Larry O'Brien believed the doctor had most likely managed to somehow switch the vials containing his blood. They took the results from their private test to law enforcement.
两周后，拉里接到了电话。结果出来了。DNA 与强奸坎迪斯的男人相符。坎迪斯欣喜若狂。她知道结果证明施尼伯格医生强奸了她。但仍不清楚为什么他的血样 DNA 与强奸犯的精液不匹配。坎迪斯和拉里·奥布莱恩认为，医生很可能以某种方式设法调换了装有他血液的小瓶。他们将私人测试的结果带给了执法部门。
Hopeful it would finally convince them of Dr. Schneeberger's guilt. Detective Harnstra of the RCMP was intrigued but told Candace the evidence couldn't be used because it had been obtained illegally. However, it might give them the leverage they needed to convince Dr. Schneeberger to provide yet another blood sample. This time they would videotape the entire process as well as watch it closely in person. When confronted with the new evidence, John Schneeberger insisted that the chapstick from the car wasn't his. Nevertheless, he agreed to provide one final sample. On November 20, 1996, Dr. Schneeberger turned up to have his blood taken by the RCMP. A serologist named Gene Roney had been brought in specifically for the task,
希望这最终能让他们相信施尼伯格医生的罪行。加拿大皇家骑警的汉斯特拉警探很感兴趣，但告诉坎迪斯，这些证据不能使用，因为它是非法获取的。然而，这可能会给他们提供说服施尼伯格医生再次提供血样所需的筹码。这一次，他们将对整个过程进行录像，并亲自密切监视。当面对新证据时，约翰·施尼伯格坚称车里的润唇膏不是他的。尽管如此，他还是同意提供最后一个样本。1996 年 11 月 20 日，施尼伯格医生现身，由加拿大皇家骑警抽取血液。一位名叫吉恩·罗尼的血清学家被专门请来执行这项任务，
with Detective Harnstra instructing her to be on the lookout for anything suspicious. A video camera was set up to record the entire thing. As Dr. Schneeberger settled in, Gene Roney asked him to stick out his hand. Blood samples were always taken from a small prick to the index finger. However, Dr. Schneeberger explained that he had a syndrome which caused his fingers to bruise easily. Having damaged fingers was less than ideal for a physician, so he offered to provide a sample from his arm instead. Gene agreed. Dr. Schneeberger rolled up the left sleeve of his yellow sweater so it sat just above his elbow.
汉斯特拉警探指示她留意任何可疑情况。一台摄像机被架设起来记录整个过程。当施尼伯格医生坐好后，吉恩·罗尼请他伸出手。血样总是从食指的小刺中提取的。然而，施尼伯格医生解释说他患有一种综合征，导致他的手指容易淤青。手指受伤对医生来说不太理想，所以他主动提出从手臂上提供样本。吉恩同意了。施尼伯格医生卷起黄色毛衣的左袖，使其刚好位于肘部上方。
The vein on the inside of his arm was prominent and should have been easy to take blood from, but Gene struggled to insert the needle. After a couple of attempts, she succeeded and drew a small sample of blood. Dr. Schneeberger was thanked and he left the room. Looking down at the blood, Gene Roney was puzzled. It was a strange color, very dark with a brownish hue. Looking at the video camera, she said, The blood doesn't look really kind of fresh.
他手臂内侧的静脉很突出，应该很容易抽血，但吉恩在插入针头时遇到了困难。经过几次尝试，她成功了并抽取了少量血液。施尼伯格医生受到感谢后离开了房间。看着血液，吉恩·罗尼感到困惑。颜色很奇怪，非常深，带有棕色调。看着摄像机，她说：“这血看起来不太新鲜。”
I don't know. The sample was submitted for analysis, but the result wasn't what anyone expected. Dr. Schneeberger's blood was too degraded to detect a DNA. Candice Foster was furious and devastated. She had fought for years to have the case reopened and now it seemed as though she had lost her last chance. As for investigators, they were suspicious. Now they were on the same page as Candice, certain that Dr. Schneeberger had done something to thwart the test, but they had no idea what.
“我不知道。”样本被提交分析，但结果并非任何人所预料。施尼伯格医生的血液降解得太严重，无法检测到 DNA。坎迪斯·福斯特既愤怒又崩溃。她多年来一直在争取重开此案，现在看来她失去了最后的机会。至于调查人员，他们很怀疑。现在他们和坎迪斯站在同一立场，确信施尼伯格医生做了什么来阻挠测试，但他们不知道是什么。
And then, in April 1997, they received a phone call from the doctor's wife, Lisa Schneeberger. On April 25, 1997, Lisa Schneeberger's 15-year-old daughter, Amy, said she had to tell her something and took Lisa to her room. Amy showed Lisa an empty condom wrapper that was lying on her bed, then stated, Mum, he's done this before. Horror washed over Lisa as she processed her daughter's words. She knew that Amy was referring to her stepfather, John Schneeberger, the love of Lisa's life and a man she had staunchly defended over the past five years. Amy's memories were blurry, but she knew that her stepfather had been sexually assaulting her for a long time, ever since she was 13. When she became a teenager, her stepfather had taken an interest in her sexual health, suggesting that Amy go on the pill.
然后，在 1997 年 4 月，他们接到了医生妻子丽莎·施尼伯格的电话。1997 年 4 月 25 日，丽莎·施尼伯格 15 岁的女儿艾米说她有话要告诉她，并把丽莎带到了她的房间。艾米向丽莎展示了躺在她床上的一个空避孕套包装纸，然后说：“妈妈，他以前也做过这种事。”恐惧笼罩着丽莎，她消化着女儿的话。她知道艾米指的是她的继父约翰·施尼伯格，他是丽莎一生的挚爱，也是她在过去五年里一直坚定捍卫的男人。艾米的记忆很模糊，但她知道继父长期以来一直在性侵她，从她 13 岁起就开始了。当她成为青少年时，继父对她的性健康产生了兴趣，建议艾米服用避孕药。
He began touching her inappropriately. Sometimes, he assaulted her in his office at work while he was supposed to be treating her for minor ailments, such as a wart on her foot. Amy could remember her stepfather giving her an injection, then guiding her to his examination table and lying on top of her. She could feel him raping her. Then she passed out. Other times, he would give her injections at night, supposedly to help her sleep. Amy would wake the next day with a hazy feeling and the knowledge that something awful had happened. The night of April 24, 1997 had been one such occasion.
他开始对她进行不当触摸。有时，他在工作办公室里袭击她，当时他本应为她治疗轻微疾病，比如脚上的疣。艾米记得继父给她注射，然后引导她到检查台上，躺在她身上。她能感觉到他在强奸她。然后她就昏过去了。其他时候，他会在晚上给她注射，据说是为了帮助她入睡。艾米第二天醒来时会有一种朦胧的感觉，并知道发生了可怕的事情。1997 年 4 月 24 日晚上就是这样的一次。
Amy hadn't been able to sleep, so her stepfather had injected her with something. The next day when she was making her bed, she had been horrified and distraught to discover a condom wrapper tucked between the sheets. Now that she had physical evidence of the assaults she had long known were taking place, Amy had decided to confide in her mother. Lisa felt sick, but she didn't doubt her daughter for a second. Memories flooded back of the way her husband had so often administered injections when the children were unwell, instead of offering tablets or syrups. Lisa had asked John why he did this, and he'd simply assured her that injections were quicker and very effective. Because he was the doctor, she had been satisfied with his answer. Lisa remembered one time when Amy had woken up feeling sick, groggy and upset, crying to her mother that John had given her a needle late at night.
艾米一直睡不着，所以继父给她注射了什么东西。第二天当她整理床铺时，她惊恐万分，发现床单间夹着一个避孕套包装纸。现在她有了长期以来一直发生的袭击的物证，艾米决定向母亲吐露心声。丽莎感到恶心，但她一秒钟也没有怀疑过女儿。记忆涌上心头，丈夫在孩子们不舒服时经常给他们注射，而不是提供药片或糖浆。丽莎问约翰为什么要这样做，他只是向她保证注射更快且非常有效。因为他是医生，她对他的回答很满意。丽莎记得有一次艾米醒来时感到恶心、昏昏沉沉且心烦意乱，哭着告诉母亲约翰在深夜给她打了一针。
When Lisa asked him about it, he'd said, yes, she was coughing. Didn't you hear her coughing? Lisa hadn't heard any coughing, but she believed her husband. As she processed the fact that her life as she knew it was a lie and the enormity of Amy's suffering, Lisa asked her daughter why she hadn't come to her sooner. Amy replied, you didn't believe Candice, why would you believe me? In an instant, Lisa knew that Candice Foster had been telling the truth all along. As reported by Crime magazine, she later told the Canadian television program W5, I felt sick, I still blame myself. Maybe if I had believed Candice, none of this would have happened to my daughter. Lisa helped Amy pack a bag so she could stay elsewhere for the weekend. Then she called her husband on his cell phone.
当丽莎问他时，他说：“是的，她在咳嗽。你没听到她咳嗽吗？”丽莎没听到任何咳嗽声，但她相信她的丈夫。当她意识到她所知道的生活是一个谎言以及艾米所受痛苦的严重性时，丽莎问女儿为什么不早点告诉她。艾米回答说：“你不相信坎迪斯，你为什么会相信我？”瞬间，丽莎知道坎迪斯·福斯特一直都在说真话。据《犯罪》杂志报道，她后来告诉加拿大电视节目 W5：“我感到恶心，我仍然责怪自己。也许如果我当时相信坎迪斯，这一切就不会发生在我的女儿身上。”丽莎帮艾米收拾了一个包，这样她周末可以住在别处。然后她用手机给丈夫打了电话。
He was in the car, driving home from a medical conference. Amy's told me what you've been doing to her. I know, said Lisa. You've done it to Candice too, didn't you? Dr Schneeberger insisted that he hadn't done anything at all and would explain everything when he got home. When he arrived home a little while later, the doctor didn't seem altogether well. He was slurring his words and Lisa suspected he had taken some kind of drug. Dr Schneeberger slept it off on the couch while Lisa lay awake all night. Early the next morning, she demanded he leave. He did and Lisa turned her attention to his home office. Casting her eyes around the room, she spotted a box perched high up on a shelf.
他在车里，正从医学会议开车回家。“艾米告诉我你对她做了什么。我知道了，”丽莎说。“你也对坎迪斯做了，不是吗？”施尼伯格医生坚称他什么都没做，并说等他回家后会解释一切。不久后他到家时，医生看起来不太好。他说话含糊不清，丽莎怀疑他服用某种药物。施尼伯格医生在沙发上睡着了，而丽莎整晚都躺着没睡。第二天一早，她要求他离开。他照做了，丽莎把注意力转向了他的家庭办公室。环顾房间，她发现架子高处放着一个盒子。
After lifting it off and opening it up, Lisa saw it was filled with doctor's gloves, syringes, condoms and vials of a drug called Versed. A benzodiazepine medication, Versed is a sedative sometimes used to decrease agitation and induce sleepiness. It is also used for anesthesia and can cause those injected with it to lose consciousness. Additionally, Versed has an amnesiac effect, preventing the formation of new memories. Lisa placed a phone call to Detective Hansstra at the RCMP and reported her husband for rape, telling the detective everything that Amy had told her. When Candice learned that Dr Schneeberger had been accused of raping his stepdaughter repeatedly over the past two years, she burst into tears. Ever since she had been raped by the doctor in 1992, she had been terrified that he would do the same thing to other women. To learn that he had repeatedly victimized an underage girl was her greatest nightmare realized.
把它拿下来打开后，丽莎看到里面装满了医用手套、注射器、避孕套和名为“咪达唑仑”的药物小瓶。咪达唑仑是一种苯二氮卓类药物，是一种有时用于减少躁动和诱导睡意的镇静剂。它也用于麻醉，并可能导致注射者失去知觉。此外，咪达唑仑具有健忘作用，可防止新记忆的形成。丽莎给加拿大皇家骑警的汉斯特拉警探打了个电话，举报了她丈夫的强奸罪，并告诉警探艾米告诉她的一切。当坎迪斯得知施尼伯格医生被指控在过去两年里多次强奸继女时，她泪流满面。自从 1992 年被医生强奸以来，她一直害怕他会对其他女性做同样的事情。得知他多次伤害未成年女孩，她最大的噩梦成真了。
The RCMP obtained a warrant and took the box that Lisa Schneeberger had found into evidence. Then they arrested her husband and charged him with aggravated sexual assault against Amy. Now that they had a warrant, they could take as much DNA from him as they wanted. Detectives took swabs of his saliva, 25 hairs from his head, and a sample of blood from his index finger. Candice Foster was thrilled. She later told producers for the television program Forensic Files. That was what I had wanted all along. I mean, I had even offered to go chop an arm off. I would have sucked him one in the nose to get that blood. No problem. This time, all of the samples had the same DNA profile as the person who had left a semen stain on Candice Foster's underwear.
加拿大皇家骑警获得了搜查令，并将丽莎·施尼伯格发现的盒子作为证据带走。然后他们逮捕了她的丈夫，并指控他严重性侵艾米。现在他们有了搜查令，可以随心所欲地从他身上提取 DNA。侦探们采集了他的唾液拭子、25 根头发和食指的血样。坎迪斯·福斯特欣喜若狂。她后来告诉电视节目《法医档案》的制片人：“那是我一直想要的。我的意思是，我甚至提出去砍掉一只手臂。我会打他的鼻子来获取那份血液。没问题。”这一次，所有的样本都与在坎迪斯·福斯特内裤上留下精液污渍的人具有相同的 DNA 图谱。
Finally, there was incontrovertible evidence tying Dr Schneeberger to Candice's case. Despite this, the doctor continued to deny that he raped Candice and denied raping his stepdaughter as well. John Schneeberger claimed that Candice was trying to destroy his wealth and his family by accusing him of rape. She had obtained his semen by breaking into his home, stealing a used condom, and then wiping its contents onto her underwear. Dr Schneeberger said that he'd realized he was being set up by Candice from the moment she lodged her report. So when the police initially asked for a blood sample, he concocted a scheme to foil the DNA test. Two weeks after the alleged rape on October 31, 1992, the doctor had an appointment with a young male patient who had a stomach complaint. Under the guise of treating him, Dr Schneeberger withdrew the patient's blood, deliberately taking more than he needed.
最终，有了无可辩驳的证据将施尼伯格医生与坎迪斯的案件联系起来。尽管如此，医生仍然否认强奸了坎迪斯，也否认强奸了继女。约翰·施尼伯格声称坎迪斯试图通过指控他强奸来摧毁他的财富和家庭。她是通过闯入他的家，偷走一个用过的避孕套，然后将其内容物擦在内裤上来获取他的精液的。施尼伯格医生说，从坎迪斯提交报告的那一刻起，他就意识到自己被坎迪斯陷害了。所以当警方最初要求提供血样时，他策划了一个阴谋来破坏 DNA 测试。1992 年 10 月 31 日所谓的强奸案发生两周后，医生与一名患有胃病的年轻男性病人有预约。在治疗的幌子下，施尼伯格医生抽取了病人的血液，故意抽取了比他需要的更多的量。
Then he placed it in a fridge in his clinic. Hours before he was required to provide his first blood sample on November 16, Dr Schneeberger took a scalpel and sliced his left upper arm, deep into his bicep. Then he took a 15cm long plastic tube that he'd filled with his patient's blood and inserted it into the cut, forcing the tube inside his arm and down to his elbow. From the outside, it looked like a protruding vein. When the lab technician took a sample from Dr Schneeberger, he insisted that it would need to be taken from his arm, not his finger. Because Dr Schneeberger wasn't under arrest, the police were relying on his cooperation and could only take what he would allow them to. Unknowingly, the technician had inserted the syringe into the prominent tube instead of a vein and withdrawn someone else's blood. Dr Schneeberger repeated the same process every time he had to provide more blood.
随后，他将血袋放在诊所的冰箱里。在11月16日首次被要求提供血样前的几个小时，施尼伯格医生用手术刀切开了左上臂，深及肱二头肌。接着，他拿出一根装满病人血液的15厘米长塑料管，将其插入伤口，强行塞进手臂并一直推到肘部。从外面看，这就像是一条突出的静脉。当实验室技术员采集施尼伯格医生的样本时，他坚持要求必须从手臂而非手指采集。由于施尼伯格医生并未被捕，警方依赖他的配合，只能采集他允许的样本。技术员在不知情的情况下，将注射器插入了那根突出的管子而非静脉，从而抽走了别人的血液。每次需要提供更多血样时，施尼伯格医生都会重复这一过程。
In video footage of him providing his third sample in 1996, there is a moment where the top of the tube can be seen protruding from the doctor's skin as he rolls up his sleeve for the test. By the time he gave this third and final sample, the blood he had taken from his patient four years earlier had grown old and died. When it was sent off for DNA testing, a report came back that it was too degraded to provide a profile. Investigators approached the patient whose blood was used by Dr Schneeberger and asked if they could test his DNA. It came back as a perfect match to the blood provided in the doctor's first two tests. In addition to the charge of aggravated sexual assault against his stepdaughter, Dr Schneeberger was charged with one count of sexual assault against Candice Foster. He was also charged with two counts of administering a noxious substance to commit an indictable offense and one count of obstruction of justice. His medical license was suspended and he finally went to trial in September of 1999.
在1996年他提供第三次样本的录像中，当他卷起袖子准备测试时，可以看到管子的顶端从医生的皮肤中突出。到他提供这第三次也是最后一次样本时，他四年前从病人那里抽取的血液已经变质死亡。当样本被送去进行DNA检测时，报告显示血液降解严重，无法提供分析结果。调查人员联系了那位被施尼伯格医生盗用血液的病人，询问是否可以检测他的DNA。结果显示，这与医生前两次测试中提供的血液完全吻合。除了对继女的严重性侵指控外，施尼伯格医生还被控对坎迪斯·福斯特进行了一项性侵犯。他还被控两项为实施可起诉罪行而投喂有害物质罪，以及一项妨碍司法公正罪。他的行医执照被吊销，并最终于1999年9月受审。
Prosecutors informed the court that the defendant was an intelligent but manipulative man who could not control his sexual impulses. Dr Schneeberger took the stand in his defense, saying that the police and his accusers were out to get him. He repeated his theory that Candice Foster had stolen his semen to frame him and explained how he had used the patient's blood as his only defense against the crooked system. Candice stared at him wide-eyed as he revealed the way he had thwarted the DNA tests. She later described the description of the surgery he'd performed on himself as disgusting. Hearing the gory lengths he had gone to to evade capture had left her feeling as though she was going to have a panic attack. When it came time for Candice to give evidence, she stood her ground as Dr Schneeberger's lawyer tried to undermine her testimony. Candice later said in an episode of Forensic Files,
检察官告知法庭，被告是一个聪明但善于操纵的人，无法控制自己的性冲动。施尼伯格医生在辩护席上声称，警方和指控他的人都在针对他。他重申了自己的理论，即坎迪斯·福斯特偷了他的精液来陷害他，并解释了他如何利用病人的血液作为对抗腐败体制的唯一防御手段。当他揭露自己如何挫败DNA测试时，坎迪斯瞪大了眼睛盯着他。她后来形容他对自己进行手术的描述令人作呕。听到他为了逃避抓捕而采取的血腥手段，让她感觉自己快要恐慌发作了。当坎迪斯出庭作证时，尽管施尼伯格的律师试图破坏她的证词，她依然立场坚定。坎迪斯后来在《法医档案》的一集中说道：
I was a bulldog on the stand. I kicked his lawyer's ass. I showed him who was boss. Lisa Schneeberger and her daughter Amy also gave evidence against the man who had once been a part of their family. On November 25, 1999, Dr John Schneeberger was found guilty of sexually assaulting Candice and Amy, of drugging Candice and obstruction of justice. However, the presiding judge acquitted Dr Schneeberger of aggravated sexual assault against Amy and of drugging her. The doctors claim that he was framed by Candice was dismissed as, quote, inventive, fanciful and imaginative. Despite the evidence against him, Dr Schneeberger remained a popular figure in Kipling and half of those in the public gallery hung their heads in sorrow upon hearing the verdict. Others, including Candice Foster and her supporters, clapped and cheered, with some people calling out, by John. Although the charges Dr Schneeberger was convicted of were enough to result in a life sentence, he was given just six years in prison.
我在证人席上表现得像只斗牛犬。我狠狠教训了他的律师。我让他知道谁才是老大。丽莎·施尼伯格和她的女儿艾米也对这个曾经是她们家庭一员的男人提出了指控。1999年11月25日，约翰·施尼伯格医生被判性侵坎迪斯和艾米、给坎迪斯下药以及妨碍司法公正罪名成立。然而，主审法官判决施尼伯格医生对艾米的严重性侵和下药指控不成立。医生声称自己被坎迪斯陷害的说法被驳回，称其为“虚构、离奇且富有想象力”。尽管有对他不利的证据，施尼伯格医生在基普林仍然是一个受欢迎的人物，旁听席上的一半人在听到判决时垂头丧气。其他人，包括坎迪斯·福斯特和她的支持者，则鼓掌欢呼，有些人甚至喊道：“再见，约翰。”虽然施尼伯格医生被判的罪名足以让他被判终身监禁，但他最终只被判处六年监禁。
Upon hearing the length of the sentence, those celebrating his conviction grew quiet and solemn. Candice would later tell the media that the amount of time the doctor had received was shorter than the length she had waited to hear it. Even when John Schneeberger was behind bars, many people throughout Kipling remained convinced that he was innocent. Some speculated that he had been framed by Candice and the RCMP. Candice dismissed Dr Schneeberger's supporters as disgruntled and ignorant former patients with no understanding of the pain and trauma he had caused. Even though Lisa Schneeberger had publicly supported her husband for years before turning against him, suspicious locals theorized that she had forced her daughter to accuse him of rape. In an interview with the Calgary Herald newspaper, Lisa asked, What would I have to gain from setting my daughter up to it? I had a husband I adored and a beautiful family. Why would I trade in that for the nightmare I'm living now?
听到刑期后，那些庆祝他被定罪的人变得安静而严肃。坎迪斯后来告诉媒体，医生得到的刑期比她等待判决的时间还要短。即使约翰·施尼伯格身陷囹圄，基普林仍有许多人坚信他是无辜的。一些人猜测他是被坎迪斯和加拿大皇家骑警陷害的。坎迪斯驳斥了施尼伯格医生的支持者，称他们是不满且无知的病人，根本不了解他所造成的痛苦和创伤。尽管丽莎·施尼伯格在反戈一击前曾公开支持丈夫多年，但多疑的当地人推测是她强迫女儿指控他强奸。在接受《卡尔加里先驱报》采访时，丽莎问道：“如果我让女儿去指控他，我能得到什么？我有一个我深爱的丈夫和一个美丽的家庭。我为什么要用这些去换取我现在所经历的噩梦？”
The only doubt I have in my mind is what part of our marriage was real. Lisa divorced Dr Schneeberger and changed her name. Even though the former doctor was now a convicted sexual offender serving time, the courts demanded that Lisa allow him visitation time with their two daughters, now aged five and six. Lisa refused, not wanting to take her children to a prison or make them spend time with the man who had raped their older sister. She was issued with a $2,000 fine for ignoring the court's orders and paid it in full. When her struggle came to the public's attention, people rallied around Lisa in support. In April 2001, when she was once again required to take her daughters to see their father, 100 protesters gathered outside the prison on the day of the visit. Lisa's daughters cried as she led them to the interview room, and their obvious distress led to the court appointed social worker canceling the meeting at the last minute.
我心中唯一的疑问是，我们婚姻中哪一部分是真实的。丽莎与施尼伯格医生离婚并改了名字。尽管这位前医生现在是一名被定罪的性犯罪者，正在服刑，但法院仍要求丽莎允许他探视他们现在分别为五岁和六岁的两个女儿。丽莎拒绝了，她不想带孩子去监狱，也不想让她们与那个强奸了她们姐姐的男人待在一起。她因无视法院命令被罚款2000美元，并全额支付了罚款。当她的抗争引起公众注意时，人们纷纷站出来支持丽莎。2001年4月，当她再次被要求带女儿去见父亲时，100名抗议者在探视当天聚集在监狱外。当丽莎带着女儿走向会面室时，孩子们哭了，她们明显的痛苦导致法院指定的社会工作者在最后一刻取消了会面。
Eventually, Dr Schneeberger agreed to give up his parental rights and visitation was no longer required. In 2003, Schneeberger was released on parole after serving four years. He moved to Regina, Saskatchewan, the same city where Candace Foster was residing. Speaking to the media, she remarked, I guess I can't escape him. Stripped of his medical license, John Schneeberger took up work with a demolition crew, but his time in his adopted country was to be short-lived as a campaign began to revoke his Canadian citizenship as well. John Schneeberger had become a Canadian citizen in 1993, the year after Candace first accused him of rape. His ex-wife Lisa pointed out that if he hadn't cheated a DNA test with a stolen blood sample, then his status as a rapist would have been known when his application was lodged.
最终，施尼伯格医生同意放弃监护权，探视要求不再被执行。2003年，施尼伯格服刑四年后获得假释。他搬到了萨斯喀彻温省的里贾纳，也就是坎迪斯·福斯特居住的城市。在接受媒体采访时，她说：“我想我无法逃避他。”约翰·施尼伯格被吊销了行医执照，开始在拆迁队工作，但他在这个收留国的时间注定很短，因为一场撤销他加拿大公民身份的运动开始了。约翰·施尼伯格于1993年成为加拿大公民，那是在坎迪斯首次指控他强奸的第二年。他的前妻丽莎指出，如果他没有用偷来的血样欺骗DNA测试，那么在他申请公民身份时，他强奸犯的身份就会被曝光。
Consequently, he should have never received citizenship at all. Canadian authorities agreed, and in 2004, the now 43-year-old John Schneeberger lost his citizenship. He had a garage sale to get rid of his belongings, and some friends and supporters threw him a going-away party before he was deported to South Africa in July. Schneeberger moved in with his mother in Durban. He attempted to join the Health Professions Council of South Africa in a bid to work in medicine once again. Just as the council was considering his application, he made the sudden and unexplained decision to withdraw it. In John Schneeberger's homeland, the South African press have dubbed him Dr Rape. His ex-wife Lisa came to view the man she once believed was her best friend and soulmate as a pathological liar and remorseless predator.
因此，他本不该获得公民身份。加拿大当局表示同意，2004年，现年43岁的约翰·施尼伯格失去了公民身份。他举办了一场车库拍卖来处理掉自己的财物，一些朋友和支持者在他7月被驱逐出境前为他举办了欢送会。施尼伯格搬到了德班与母亲同住。他试图加入南非健康专业委员会，以期重返医疗行业。就在委员会考虑他的申请时，他突然做出了无法解释的决定，撤回了申请。在约翰·施尼伯格的祖国，南非媒体称他为“强奸医生”。他的前妻丽莎开始将这个她曾经认为是最好朋友和灵魂伴侣的男人视为一个病态的骗子和毫无悔意的掠夺者。
Her greatest regret was not believing Candace Foster, and she blamed herself for the abuse that later took place in her home. When Lisa heard that John Schneeberger had finally left Canada, she told the Saskatchewan News Network, quote, I'm elated. It is such a relief to know he's gone. It has often been a long and painful journey. I am so looking forward to closing that last final chapter and putting that book away forever. Candace Foster had dreams about John Schneeberger for years. In some, he chased her down while she tried to escape and she would wake up screaming. In others, she would pursue him with a gun, waking only after she had shot him in the head. I don't know if it will ever go away, she told the Calgary Herald in an interview.
她最大的遗憾是没有相信坎迪斯·福斯特，并为后来发生在自己家中的虐待行为自责。当丽莎听说约翰·施尼伯格终于离开加拿大时，她告诉萨斯喀彻温新闻网：“我欣喜若狂。知道他走了真是一种解脱。这往往是一段漫长而痛苦的旅程。我非常期待合上那最后一章，永远把那本书收起来。”坎迪斯·福斯特多年来一直梦见约翰·施尼伯格。在一些梦里，他在她试图逃跑时追赶她，她会尖叫着醒来。在另一些梦里，她会拿着枪追赶他，直到开枪击中他的头部后才会醒来。“我不知道这种阴影是否会消失，”她在接受《卡尔加里先驱报》采访时说。
When you are raped, it never ever goes away. Candace took John Schneeberger to court in a civil suit and was eventually awarded $75,000, but it is unclear whether she received this money. Candace told newspaper The Edmonton Journal that she was less concerned about the money than she was some form of compensation for all that she had lost. He stole time with my baby daughter from me. I'm never going to get those years back. About a decade after her attack, Candace co-wrote a script about the ordeal which was subsequently made into a film called I Accus. Her hope was that it would inspire other survivors of rape to come forward to share their stories. No matter how they are perceived by their communities. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当你被强奸时，这种阴影永远不会消失。坎迪斯在民事诉讼中将约翰·施尼伯格告上法庭，最终获得了7.5万美元的赔偿，但目前尚不清楚她是否收到了这笔钱。坎迪斯告诉《埃德蒙顿日报》，她对钱的关心程度远不及对她所失去的一切寻求某种补偿。“他偷走了我和幼女相处的时间。我永远也找不回那些年了。”在遭受袭击大约十年后，坎迪斯合写了一个关于这段经历的剧本，随后被拍成了一部名为《我控诉》的电影。她的希望是，这能激励其他强奸幸存者站出来分享她们的故事。无论她们在社区中如何被看待。谢谢。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。